do you want to know one of the saddest
realizations I recently had was that as
a liberal woman it is really hard to
find a man who was willing to play the
more traditional masculine role in the
relationship in today's day and age who
is not a conservative a man who wants to
pay on the first date who wants to
it's so hard
to find
a conservative man
that is not conservative
you don't use the difference between
traditional conservative
yes I understand that but
you being liberal and stuff like that is
not
traditional
that's not traditional
and most people that are conservative
tend to be more traditional I know
there's a difference I absolutely know
there's a difference
but
they are very close
very close almost similar
what you're asking for
is something that is not traditional so
you're surprised
that people that are conservative
and ten more to traditional things
that's what you want but you don't want
the frame of mind to get them to be
traditional you actually want to go you
don't want a man you want to go take a
trip in the Okanagan Valley and pick
cherries
that's what you want to do
you want to pick cherries
go there pick cherries for a summer make
your money and come back
hmm
that's what it is
no matter I mean I'm not either she
wants to choose her boyfriend the same
way I choose an RPG character she want
to be like three points at the Charisma
minus five points into conservatism uh
seven points into traditional factors
eight points into using the proper
pronouns right she want to be able to
make a Build-A-Bear husband go in the
Okanagan Valley pick cherries my guy I
don't know what that means for sure
uh when you're like come you come in a
team white people when they come into
teens and they're in Quebec oftentimes
they travel to uh to British Columbia to
pick cherries right nobody's gonna catch
this reference other than you and like
somebody it's fine it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter the
point is not where you're going and this
and that is you're going out there
cherry picking that's that's the whole
system okay it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter I'm like why are we going to
Japan to pick cherries that it doesn't
matter because I didn't even know they
had cherries in the pan yes in what I
thought they only had a plum blossoms in
Japan okay
okay now
say that again Okinawa
yeah they sound like brothers and
cousins what don't even come for me
I'm not going nowhere
very thought it was Asian too okay
Noggin this is actually Fair listen it's
and if you think about it natives are
just like
Forest agents so it's the same thing uh
no Asian's the first Native anyways
let's keep going and
I was a liberal woman I do expected from
Independence I
have my own autonomy in the relationship
and not be confined or conformed to the
traditional female Homemaker child
bearing role and most of the men that
I've dated who do have that more natural
provider masculinity about them are
normally conservative so I don't really
know what to do because I don't want to
compromise my morals and values just to
find a man but am I asking to have my
cake and eat it too yes yes yes yes yes
yes you are because we all know I don't
want to compromise you said it right
there I do not want to compromise you
said this standard that is
kind of contradicting but whatever all
right and then
those mans probably exist but yeah so
does unicorns you understand what I'm
saying it's like
I don't want to play the end again I
didn't hear what she said
just to find a man but am I asking how
my cake you need it too yeah asking how
my cake can eat it too I have my cake
and eat it too okay okay sorry I heard
what you heard yeah okay but okay I know
what you meant yeah
um I just think it's interesting
that as you become more Progressive you
don't want to compromise your morals and
values but you expect people to
compromise more traditional men to do
this do that oh to me it's just uh
endemic of the fact that I think people
want to not be non-traditional and still
expect traditional from other people
she's saying she wants to be independent
and do her thing and have her career but
also have a man take care of her and
it's just it's funny to me how
women can evolve as much as they want
but they want men to also evolve but
also stay the same they want a man to
evolve in the way they want
which and it's fine and it's fine and
it's totally fine it's okay
again nah not all women we know that but
that particular woman and the type of
woman like that one evil however way
they want
but men are not going to evolve however
waiting one no they're gonna evolve
according to my standards and I'm gonna
have to find yeah okay and that's fine
to have centers I I'm I'm rooting for
you uh live your life
but you're gonna be less likely to find
that it's very contradicting uh but it's
fine I mean hope more more life you see
how difficult it is yeah I can
understand how difficult it is
yeah it's like you want to be the
president of your country and also be
treated like a princess it's just funny
it's like
that's a girl Boss by day no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no that and no
that's what they want the first one
you want to be the president that was
fire you want to be the president
yeah that's what she was that she
want to be in the p and the P yeah she
want to be the P the P but yeah that
could be that could be a thing you want
to be the PNP she want to be the P the p
I just wonder when people record these
kind of videos they just don't hear
themselves like you have to go to the
process of adding subtitles doing all
that editing to upload it and you didn't
stop and think wait
don't I already have the answer
if you want it's like you're expecting
from him something you're not willing to
do yourself you want him to compromise
but you don't want to compromise that's
it I don't know so let me tell you and
then you find it difficult because you
don't want to compromise sounds dumb to
me and counterproductive but that you do
you want yo I want a girl who sucks dick
like a prawn star and is still a virgin
it's like okay come on now B I mean we
could all wish I guess what did she
learn
the street you know like everything is
going to have a trade-off everything's
gonna have a compromise nobody finding
the perfect partner so you got to find
out where you're gonna give you're gonna
have to find out what You Gotta Give
but this kind of talk is just weird and
it made me think of like all the ladies
who are just like the most Progressive
people I knew but then expected men to
like still pay on the first date to
still do all this like traditional masks
and stuff and I don't mind I don't think
there's anything wrong with those things
but the expectation of it is what I
think is funny as we're changing and
society's changing it's just interesting
that like there's constant demands of
meant to change but like you know what
you know that portion where you as a man
just take charge of situations and do
all this other stuff that's like born
from the patriarchy but we think is good
we want you to keep that it's like okay
okay
this is
but we want nothingness what do you guys
is this ridiculous is it acceptable she
being
insane right now obviously you should
delete this video private or her account
once this went viral because people were
mocking her and look I I don't think
it's one of those things where people
gotta send hate mail to people like
whatever people got a dumb take or
whatever it's like
um but yeah that's what happens you're
gonna say
internet when you put stuff like that
when you have a lack of self-awareness
like that and you just post it like that
and like why do you think people will
tell you what you think true they will
tell you what they think and they'll be
like yo you you bucking
okay you post yourself like that I was
just thinking I just came there and you
don't have self-awareness people will
will make you aware of things but let's
let's let's let's let's take it from her
perspective
I think women probably feel at their
best
in relationship Dynamics when they have
a man who takes care of them not like it
buys everything or whatever but
generally makes them feel safe protected
uh you know goes out of their way to be
a gentleman or whatever so even though
these are things that are emblematical
like the patriarch and the way things
used to be
right that is I think I suspect what
women I could be wrong it's been what
I've seen the most okay uh they still
love that even though they're fed a lot
of this Progressive narrative like do
this or a girl independent you don't
need no man I think when the confines a
relationship happens they realize they
like that overly masculine man who's
just like girl you ain't gotta work I
got this all whatever right yeah
um so I guess it's got to be conflicting
to some degree
it's like you got this really good
feeling of
like primally I'm just theorizing I'm
trying to understand the mindset like
from a primal standpoint she probably
just feels like oh this is the kind of
relationship that makes me feel good but
politically it doesn't align with the
kind of life I want to live so how do
you justify those two things because she
said she found that stuff but it was
with men who were conservative and it
made her feel uneasy she couldn't handle
it she couldn't handle the fact that
they voted for Trump
but God is going to vote for Trump is
more likely to shoot another guy that's
gonna and protect you and protect their
family
then call 9-1-1 and stuff like that and
wait for the police to get there even if
it takes three hours I know I already
called
right
so
yeah have men have to change certain
standards compromise sure I think so I
think men definitely have had to change
yeah yeah part of its economic right
like you just can't expect your wife to
stay at home and you know not want to
have a job or whatever
part of it is probably values as well I
think a lot of men are pretty supportive
of the fact that their wives or their
Partners like working you know more
money more trips right my girl out here
um
I think men are probably
look if I'm taking the views that people
had before like sexual Purity at least
in the west is not as coveted as it used
to be still here's some of it but
obviously men have had to change on that
front a lot yeah
um
where else where else have men have had
to change regards to their dating
standards
well we have to lower our expectance of
if I give you something you owe me
something in return what else something
that's probably the prime things
I don't have to drive you anywhere you
have a driver's license you can you you
can afford a car so I got you
um they don't expect you the same have
the same wifely duties as you have to
now that things have become more even
and money's being distributed
differently because both people have a
job the people have to cook clean it's
got a little different different
relationships right men have had to
compromise in a lot of these Realms and
have accepted that role in a lot of ways
and so I think it's been coming on a lot
of ladies out there to also accept the
fact that these things are changing and
you just can't have everything that you
want right
you know
I'd probably say that but do you hear
guys complaining about stuff like that
like ooh
taxi I'm gonna be honest with you I know
some dudes this is funny because I date
girls sometimes like I'll do the bare
minimum they'll be impressed but it's
like
they'll date men who expect the women to
have a job and come home quick clean and
do everything yeah so there's a lot of
men actually who have completely
forfeited their responsibilities both
financially and at home so they do
actually have the best of both worlds
they got a progressive woman who makes
all the cheddar and she come home and
she's still traditional that she guys
hand all the responsibilities but we had
a couple of people like that we covered
them we have covered some of them we
have covered some of them they ain't got
the finances to live that traditional
masculine lifestyle and they still
expect them to do everything so I guess
this is probably the other side of that
coin in a way
uh the girl there uh uh just lonely
thing was saying yeah you can't get
you can't get separated over chores yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
I guess there's just some people who uh
well she doesn't have that
but she she thinks that's what out there
and that's that's what she's preaching
that's not what she's getting that could
never be but anyways let us know what
you guys think in the comments